foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Dr John deloney number one best-selling
author and Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it is a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five
two two five thank you for jumping in
America we are glad you are here so John
we um
we were talking before we got on the air
and I think it's worth just carrying
that conversation forward a little bit
there is a uh uh there seems to be a
movement or a stirring and I don't I
don't think it's coordinated I think
it's just observation by several people
who are good critical thinkers that
there's an observation by people like uh
Michael Easter who wrote the book
Comfort crisis uh by
um some of our friends over the daily
wire uh by
um uh people like Mike Rowe our friend
Mike Rowe uh this there is the uh seems
to be a separation in our culture right
now and a recognition of this like never
before between the
people who are willing to
work
um
and sacrifice and have mental or
physical calluses
calluses on your mind because you push
through you persevere through something
stressful on your hands literally
because you're doing like real work
um
verses
quiet quitting versus I'm going to work
from home which means I don't work much
I'm not really working from home there's
pretty much two categories of people all
the data starting to show us people that
work from home there are those that work
way too much
like become Workaholics at home they
don't quit they get up from dinner
abandon their kids go back to their
screen and keep working all night and
then there are those that work like two
hours a day and call that a full-time
job and play with their children in the
middle of the floor while they're
supposed to be working but there's this
group of people that are
bent on mediocrity they're bent on doing
as little as possible they are bent on
just getting by they are bent on trying
to quote cheat the system and someone
else take care of them and then there's
this group of people
that are kind of I guess old school that
are working that have work ethic that
are leaning in and they can be of any
age group it is not a a generational
thing I saw somebody today railing on
gen Z it's not gen z uh because I'm
meeting Boomers that are doing these
exact same crap one way or the other but
in a in a culture where uh a percent a
an unusually large percentage has
decided to do little or nothing if
you're willing to do a lot you're going
to stand out oh man you got chance for
Success like never before in our world
right I I I I go all the way back to
I I actually and maybe I'm crazy I or
I'm overly optimistic my wife says
sometimes I I think we got here with
good intentions back in the you remember
back in the 70s and 80s
there are some studies done that showed
man these folks who are are CEOs and
leaders they've got good self-esteem
and so what we need to give these kids
in elementary school is we just need to
tell them how great they are all the
time so they have good self-esteem and
what we missed and then we the
participation trophy was born that's
right everybody's gonna feel good about
themselves and then they'll all become
like that and what we missed is no they
became like that because they failed a
lot and they got hit in the mouth a lot
and they kept persevering and they had
people around them that walked alongside
them similarly man we everyone I just
put a thing on Instagram everyone wants
to win the Super Bowl but nobody wants
to get tackled by a 350 pound man yeah
and that's that's Tom Brady got hit a
whole bunch yeah right it's like like
his lineman got hit way more it's not
getting hit by a Kia I mean really I
mean it's just but but I want to win the
Super Bowl but I don't I don't want any
dirt under my fingernails and I don't
want to hear my joints Creak I think
it's the old Bobby Knight quote everyone
everyone wants to be win the
championship
nobody wants to practice real hard right
and you don't put that time in and I
think we have a culture of folks who
Miss they don't have a picture of what
that Gap looks like and now I actually
think it sounds old school but I'm
seeing it in the Medical Science and in
the mental health science it's a new
wave of people coming in saying
oh our bodies can't exist without stress
and tension it can't exist without
having something to push up against you
don't go to the gym and lift a ribbon
you got to put weight on that bar
otherwise your body never grows you
don't get stronger and so we I think we
have to teach a whole generation of
people
here's how to get back up you know what
part of it is too I mean you used to get
dopamine hits from stress and from
leaning into something oh dude lifting
this participation now now you get
dopamine hit from everywhere from well
this magic wand in your hand oh dude yes
you got a magic wand in your hand that
gives your dopamine hits all day long
that aren't from but there's no real
stress associated with it and so there's
this atrophying of character right that
has occurred and I I used to tell my
students
when Martin was marching across the
bridge Dr King the Assumption was you're
gonna get killed doing this and we're
going anyway that's different than the
the thumb Warriors I call them like like
launching their grenades via social
media like there's this lack of hey dude
if you're gonna get in the arena you're
gonna get hurt and that's that's part of
the whole game not you can't stay on the
outside of the arena and pretend you
participated right you got to get in
there and that means you're gonna get
knocked down and if there is no
toughness there is no perseverance if
there's no calluses there is no
perseverance and if there is no
perseverance there is no success and
then the self-esteem not not the
self-esteem and then and what you can't
do Dave you can't lie to your body you
can tell yourself you're the toughest
guy in that room you can tell yourself I
can do it I can do it your body knows
we're not ready for this and it's fluffy
there's a yeah there's a gap right it's
like oh I could do that your body's
telling you I don't think we can man
like we can don't do that don't do it
and so man get some true real
experiences underneath your belt
um yeah so when in doubt bust up into
something yes when in doubt overdo it
yes but when in doubt activity not
passive right right
um we have a culture that's overthinking
everything get out and start doing man
get out start doing a fail and quit
trying to figure out the uh the macro
economic uh Marxist angle on something
yeah good job dude yeah just just go
work
what's that line your grandma had I
loved there's a great place to go when
you're broke to work you know I mean
that's just that that but that's that's
old school right there and here's the
thing it's also new school because
really there is no success without it
right there is no success in your
marriage unless you're intentional and
you work at it that sounds very romantic
every day but you got to you know when I
got married I did you know I didn't know
beans I've read like 100 marriage books
I think you know I started raising kids
I I don't know what I was doing I
started reading parenting books you know
there's without doing it on purpose
without some lifting without some stress
without some push which always involves
a callus is developing
um there is no success so there's no
strength there's no growth looking for
uh the Amazon Prime for your life take
the hard pack you can push a button and
crap shows up on your porch take the
hard pass okay that's not how life
really works if you've been trained by
this magic wand in your hand to not lean
into the strenuous activities uh take
that thing and drop your heel down on it
and crush it and go lean into some
strenuous activities this is where the
best parts of life come from
oh that's a good start for the show open
phones are triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm Dave Ramsey that's
Dr John deloney this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com
Ramsey today and set up a free product
tour that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host Jake is with
us in New York hi Jake welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey how's it going Mr Ramsey better than
I deserve sir what's up
so I'm 23 years old and I'm wondering uh
what I'm doing right now will help me
set my retirement up you know at either
40 years old or if I'm lucky enough
early
why do you want to retire at 40.
uh
I'm kind of seeing my father who uh you
know working every day and uh
you know kind of breaking his butt I was
wondering uh
if I can retire from my main job and
focus on my main uh my own business I
would much rather do that
well let's do that before 40.
yes absolutely why don't you just do
that like soon I mean like by the time
you're 26 instead of 40. you don't have
to be retired to run your own business
matter of fact you can't be retired and
run your own business
the definition of running your own
business is you're running the business
so you're not retired and running is the
Key Word by retired you don't mean
retired you mean quit the job you hate
and do the one you love that's what you
meant right
in the short sense yeah yeah I mean you
weren't gonna like go fishing six days a
week
no at 40. that wasn't what you were
talking about you were talking about do
something you love instead of a job you
hate which is what your dad did
so do a job you hate for a little while
make as much money as you can with a
plan to open your business in the next
four to five years and then run a
business your whole life
um
I had enough money to quit working by
the time I was 40 but I didn't I work
more
because I love what I do I love running
this business I love getting to do this
show I love the things I get to do and
if I don't love them I change them
because I own it so you know that that's
uh that's the game you want to get in is
where you're just leaning into your
strengths and you're having fun most
days some days I get tired and grouchy
too but um no but um you've never seen
that shut up John but the uh
yeah you see what I'm saying Jake I mean
so it sounds like you do you do a job
right now just for money and you don't
want to have to do that for the rest of
your life
correct so I'm I'm uh I had my main job
and then I run my other job on the side
which uh I've been running it for the
last uh about a year yeah so do that for
a while let's get the job you the the
business that you want to get up get it
up and running in the next three to four
years and let that be your plan instead
of I'm gonna pile up so much money and
I'm going to work at something I hate
for 20 freaking years no I don't want to
do that and no I'm not going to tell you
to do that I would tell you instead
let's just you know make something you
love lucrative enough to live on and
grow it
and Jake I this may not be you man but I
hear the sentiment more and more I used
to hear it from my students and I'm
hearing it more and more and more
the idea of retirement used to be I want
to have enough so that when I quit
working I can like I've got enough to
live on right and then that became I
want to have all these wild adventures
all the the definition of retirement
keeps moving forward and now I'm hearing
it with young people I want to get to a
spot where I can do nothing
and I will tell you
there's no quicker way for your body to
shut down your relationships to fall
apart you will hate your life if you do
nothing that's not a goal that's not an
objective to get to that place so I like
Dave create a life that you want to live
man create a life that you want to be
involved with I had a guy on my show
called yesterday it was heartbreaking it
was tough
amazing guy who quit drinking and in his
uh sober for X number of weeks now and
here's what he said he said I
work out every day now and I'm running
out of ways to kill my kill time
and he was asking me for some other
things he could do to help kill time and
I said dude your life isn't something
you want to kill it's something to live
right and so this idea that I'm just
gonna I'm gonna get to this place when
I'm 40 then I can just do nothing that's
that's a miserable goal man it's a
miserable goal yeah get having enough
money to be independent uh that's a good
word financially independent and have
some autonomy is a good thing but uh the
goal is not to uh you know sit on the
back porch and drink all afternoon I
mean it's not you know this is not what
are you gonna do so I had a friend of
mine sold his uh business he'd grown he
started really young and he sold his
business for multiplied millions of
dollars when he was 32.
and um
he you know kind of had that goal like I
won't do nothing he said I always want
he said I'm just going to play golf and
fish and so he went fishing all the time
and he played golf all the time and he
said I got so fat
and my wife didn't like me and I didn't
like me
and I didn't even like golf or fishing
anymore and it was two of my favorite
things in the world and I hated them
because it's all I did all day long it
was like if you eat enough Lobster it
tastes like soap right you don't smoke
not good anymore though your favorite
food eat it every day you'll hate it
eventually and so
you know what he did is he went back in
business and lost his weight and is the
happiest he's ever been in his life he
does something to do every day he's got
a purpose he's got an adventure yeah it
you know honestly
bass and and Tyler's Pro V ones or not
this is not an adventure uh except on a
limited basis I mean it's not
it's just not uh uh you know now maybe
you're maybe you're a fishing guide okay
yeah you're short of that
I'm going to retire and do and just and
be a person of leisure
you know this is what we think of when
we think of dysfunctional uh zoned out
often drugged up trust fund babies are
people of leisure with their seersucker
suits sitting on the deck chair of the
Titanic you know and that that's the
problem so that's not what Jake's trying
to do but this is you and I continuing
our conversation from the first segment
here and uh so it just you know that
there's something to be said uh of um
there's a dignity that comes from
impacting things and moving things
around good good question Jake thank you
for joining us uh Georgie's with us
Georgie is in
Phoenix hi Georgie how are you
I'm great how are you guys better than I
deserve what's up
of course you are
I want to find out where I should be
throwing
I'm currently putting more than 15
towards my retirement
and uh my reason for that is I'm just
starting late in saving for retirement
or should I be putting that at my house
like you always say and get it paid off
sooner how old are you
I am 64. okay and how much do you owe on
your home
about 146 146 how much cash do you have
in non-retirement
in non-retirement 42 000. what do you
have in retirement
38 000 38 000.
yeah
all right and what do you make
about 60
okay so our goal should be two-pronged
by the time you're 76 years from now I
want the house paid for and I want a big
nest egg right we need both of those
either one of them not done is going to
leave you is going to leave you
vulnerable
and so the best way I know how to do
that is 15 towards retirement and chunk
everything else you can get on the house
and work as much as you can work if you
can pick up any extra income even throw
it at the house you'll get this house
done then we've got even more money
because we don't have a house payment
anymore to chunk at retirement and the
last couple of years you could really
build up retirement fast but if we said
okay four years to pay off the house is
forty thousand dollars a year
yeah and that puts you at 68.
true okay and so that that's going to
involve more work that's going to
involve more income than you have coming
in
okay
and so if you that that's the kind of
thing I'd love to see for you
it's not like you're going to die if you
don't do that I don't want you
misunderstanding it's not like oh God
it's
you're in pretty good shape you're
heading in the right direction you're
not out of control but if you but you
know if you can have zero debt including
your home going into your golden years
it stabilizes everything because your
largest uh line item in your budget is
housing
and when it's all paid off your largest
line item is no longer your largest line
item ding ding so it stabilizes
everything that's where I want you to go
good question Georgie thank you for
joining us this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey guys if you enjoy this
show you can help us we would appreciate
it since you don't pay anything for it
um
dude what else leave us uh leave us a uh
five-star review that helps move the
needle on uh the listenership helps
people find us and all that kind of
stuff one stars are of no value if you
can't say something nice don't say
anything at all okay so I said about
another show yeah just go you know try
something else or whatever if that's
your thing but the uh and also subscribe
click the follow the subscribe on the
whatever you do it Spotify or apple or
YouTube or wherever it is and and share
the show you can you can send the links
out uh you can tell people that this
show's on TBN now that this show is on
680 radio stations just share by just
simply telling people with you like your
lips and stuff so if you'll spread the
word for us it makes a lot of difference
help us help us help us help us also say
this Dave
um and these are words that I never
thought would uh come out of my mouth oh
you should follow me and Dave on social
media
[Laughter]
uh me and Dave are Tick Tock Sensations
and we are Instagram I'm big on Tic Tac
Instagram Sensations so follow us there
too yeah I'm a big deal on Tic Tac so
just check it out I'm I have no idea but
that's what they tell me son who knew a
boomer on Tic Tac so there you go all
right let's go to Mary and Trenton New
Jersey hi Mary how are you
hi Dave hi Dr John it's an honor to be
talking to you you too what's up um
so I actually I live in Michigan but
Trenton comes into the equation so I
live in Michigan
um my husband and I are in baby step two
right now
um I found you guys back in August and
I've been you've been helping me get
through a lot of housework but I
appreciate it I'm always plugged in to
your podcast thank you um we we own a
rental property from when we live in New
Jersey
um it's near Trenton and
um we've been rental property owners or
however you want to call it for about 18
years so that makes this the upcoming
change a little bit more like emotional
for us
um we're done
um I know I know what you would say
about having an out-of-state rental
property we're tired of it
um it pays the mortgage but we're just
tired of dealing with it and we do have
baby step two and three to take care of
if we do sell the property which is the
plan right now it will take care of baby
step two it will take care of baby step
three take care of capital gains taxes
uh fees and all that and leave us with
probably like ten thousand left over to
invest so
um I I guess my first question is is
that the right thing to do and my other
question is because I think I know the
answer to the first question is how do I
feel more comfortable with this idea and
like after all of that money Cycles
through baby step two and three
and then being left with so little in
the end it just feels kind of like
anticlimactic and disappointing
uh oh yes you've got to do it there's no
question
um that it's the right thing to do
because the way if you pan back and look
at these things the way to make the
decision and the way to feel better
about it is go okay 10 years from today
I've got two options keep this thing and
Whittle my way through this or dump this
thing which I really don't even like
anymore and make major strides forward
so 10 years from today who would you
know which married wants to look back on
this Mary and be happy with her you know
so that's going to tell you to sell it
isn't it
yeah yeah and that's also simultaneously
how you feel better about it I think is
okay this is a season
um
it's okay to say out loud I'm
emotionally invested in this and uh you
know I I'm you know I'm abandoning a
former dream that wasn't as dreamy as I
thought it was going to be called uh
landlording
uh I thought it was going to be dreaming
18 years in it's not much of a dream
it's some Nightmare and I'm kind of glad
to be out of it but I kind of am
admitting that I was you know I was on
the wrong boat for a while and now I'm
having to change boats and saying that
out loud stings a little bit right
yeah yeah but all the while you know the
grown-up part of you is saying this is
wisdom
yeah like we always did it as a
um and the future
well I guess
here you are 18 years later living in
the future it paid off I know all right
I know hey Mary have you ever have you
ever not owed anybody anything
no have you ever
had like an air conditioner brake or a
roof leak and you started laughing
no
so yeah you're talking to two guys who
are on the other side of that
who both of us have paced around the
house unable to breathe because our
wives were asleep and we didn't know how
we're going to pay our bills
I didn't know how to tell my wife that
we
our our net worth was in the negative by
hundreds of thousands of dollars I don't
know how to say those words and now I
can tell you on the other end when our
air conditioner busted and we started
dying laughing not because we're rich or
we got money but we had an emergency
fund and no debt and we didn't owe
anybody any money and so we started
laughing not because we're happy to
spend 10 grand but because of course it
happens right around Christmas or
whatever the thing was okay so it's not
me being flipping it's me being saying
what I can tell you on the other side of
where you are
peace is worth every everything you will
go through selling this house
now I think more than anything you're
just grieving the eye the thing that oh
I thought this thing was going to be the
answer to all my problems and now all
these 18 years later dealing with it
it's not it just helps a little
and so it it just you know uh it it was
a disappointment
yeah you gotta grieve it man it's not
it's not it's not what you thought it
was going to be I thought I'd have 30
houses in 18 years right yeah I got one
and I don't like it and it's not even
fun yeah so yeah it's time to do it be
the grown-up hold your build your breath
hold your nose get your work done eat
your broccoli and uh then you'll be
healthy and strong
Josh is in Green Bay Wisconsin hey Josh
what's up
hi Dave how are you doing better than we
deserve how can we help
um so I just had a
college versus career so I had a career
beforehand and then me and my wife
decided this last year that I'd go ahead
and go back to college for an
engineering degree
um I'm just kind of second guessing it
because it's just we went from such a a
much larger income down to a single
income and I'm just kind of wondering if
maybe I should just go back to working
full-time at my previous career if I
should continue with college
uh how long is your is your career going
to be how long are you going to make
less money
um it'll be for the full four years
welcome in college and then on the back
end how much more
money are you gonna make
um
hopefully hopefully around like 20 000
more or so
um I don't think it's gonna be okay when
you started this process you knew every
bit of this
yeah what changed
um I think it's just
I'll tell you engineering's hard
right that's you and there's a bunch of
20 year old Knuckleheads in there that
don't know what they're like and they're
complaining about stuff and you're like
you have no idea about the real world
and it's a drag and you don't like
homework and you want to play with your
kids and do whatever it just it sucks
right
and so you want to quit
well I feel like that's part of it and
part of it's just like I I kind of have
money as a big security blanket for me
because you knew that before we started
to have a lot of it around so you knew
that before you started this that
doesn't change
so other than engineering's hard what
changed
um I think I just want to have more
money saved up in the long run I suppose
and I thought I'd be a little more
comfortable with it than I am like now
but
in two different times when I chose to
go back for a not just to spend money on
a
nonsense degree but with an
intentionality for a career on the other
side of it it's worked out exponentially
for me
that's all I can tell you my personal
experience I've done it twice
so um what does your wife make
uh she makes 75 000 a year what did you
use to make
I used to make 70 000 and what do you
make now
nothing I don't make anything she's not
working
no why
uh it was just kind of challenging with
all the homework and extra stuff on the
side oh come on I got two phds with a
full-time job brother no sympathy here
get a job too get a job too come on go
work you can do it and kids work in
college all the time dude don't quit now
like a grown-up and stuff you can still
work while you're in college
be easier for you because you're more
mature yeah I got homework no you're
gonna get a job man and finish your dad
gum degree
plow through you got this uh it's worth
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
car debt is at an all-time high in
history more credit card debt than any
time in history right now with debt
payments and inflation stealing more and
more of your paycheck a lot of people
feel like they're drowning they're
scared to death they don't have enough
to take care of your family if you're
ready to say I've had it
we're ready to help you Financial Peace
University will do it it's our nine
lesson course that teaches you how to
beat debt and build wealth it's
everything you wish you'd learned about
how to handle money
nearly 10 million people have taken
Financial Peace University
and uh they'll tell you that they don't
worry about money like they used to
they're in control and you can be too
so decide you're done with the stressing
out decide you're done with the losing
the money battle it's just silly I mean
time to change something start Financial
Peace University at ramseysolutions.com
FPU ramseysolutions.com slash FPU thanks
for joining us America Eugene Oregon
Tyler's up hey Tyler welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello how you guys doing better than we
deserve what's up
okay so
um I'm an electrical contractor and I
have a commercial property uh we live in
the back portion of it but I'm upgrading
the front for storefront and I want to I
need to build an accessory building for
because I'm branching out to a lighting
store and I need storage but I want to
pay off my loan ASAP
and I don't know which way if I should
expand the business to try and bring
more money or just pay it off and then
do it in a year or two it's actually
probably next year payable enough or do
it this year that's really the question
yeah so one year swing
yeah okay
um so you pay your loan off your loan on
what
the property
okay so the commercial building has a
loan
yes and either you and you have a you
have a stack of money and that stack of
money will either pay that loan off or
build the storage and if you pay the
loan off then you can build a storage
next year
yes do that pay the loan off now
no-brainer oh okay okay you wanna know
why
sure yes I will don't do it because I
should do it because you know why okay
okay
no risk
when you're running a business and you
have little to no risk because you don't
have a mortgage anymore
you make different decisions
you're more bold you're more creative
you're more turned loose into the
business
I am
much more bold with our business
decisions
because I don't have any stinking
payments anywhere in my life and none of
those decisions are going to be the end
of me financially
and so I can reach over there and drop
some coin on something and hope it works
and and do everything I was smart and
wise and try to make it work but if it
doesn't work it's not the end of me does
that make sense
that makes that makes perfect sense and
so what people what you can't really put
into numbers
is this entrepreneurial freedom and
boldness and creativity that happens
when you don't have any debt anymore
because stuff is going to come at us I
mean we've got inflation coming at us
we've got uh you know we've got uh
pandemic quarantines coming at us we got
balloons coming at us we got we got
stuff coming at us heads are falling off
yes yeah we got stuff we got stuff we
got stuff coming at us everywhere and so
you know you just have all these these
threats
these existential threats you know where
they're coming and you don't know when
they're coming what what what what's the
next thing going to be I guarantee you
if you'd pulled a million Americans
a giant balloon floating across the sky
would not have entered anyone's not a
single person's mind not one not even
the conspiracy theories conspiracy
Rachel could not have cooked up Rachel
Rachel Cruz the king queen of conspiracy
theories would not have entered into the
balloon world so I mean there's never no
there's always an existential threat I
mean and if not just watch the news
they'll give you one and so you know the
the thing is uh and the truth is there's
outside variables coming at you all the
time in business and there they are they
do somebody opens up a shop right across
the street or they do create risk and so
and all of a sudden you're going I'm
really glad
our own payments
and that means I could go to this and I
can counter punch this way and I can
fight this one to the death and I can
choose to walk away from that other one
and um you got all kinds of stuff here
just and it it changes the uh The Way
You Walk changes your body uh language
you know you're you're it's hard for me
to describe but I've been working with
uh Small Business Leaders for 25 years
teaching people this and I see it all
the time I see their their world expand
and grow when they get rid of the weight
that they didn't even know was there and
my guess is you probably build a
different shop a year from now you don't
have any payments let me tell you this
for sure
if you build anything with debt or you
build it with cash you will build
different that's right a hundred percent
because that cash is like real money
and that debt is like it's somebody
else's money it's like Monopoly money
you do not emotionally pay attention
with borrowed money like you do when
it's your freaking money that's right
even like even if you guys just buying a
car out there just for your house right
it's not a business decision we're gonna
go buy a car and uh when you when you
when you pay cash you're like are
studying this puppy I'm looking I'm
going to read every the article on it
and uh you know I don't know the green
ones don't have good resale you know and
everyone's got it for 48 dollars cheaper
I'm gonna go to that car yeah and you're
when you're like um
you know as you're borrowing money to do
it you're like yeah just sign right here
I'm out here
I'm out I gotta go to Chick-fil-A I'm
out of here you know
Connie's with us Connie
is in Phoenix hi Connie how are you
uh doing great today guys thanks for
taking my call appreciate it sure what's
up
uh I was in a vehicle accident on
January 2nd hit and run vehicle was
totaled you okay find myself without a
vehicle uh yeah nothing time won't heal
wow sorry some stitches in the eyes whoa
It's a real wreck some uh some uh neck
pain and but nothing that time won't
heal I'll be fine wow I'm sorry a scary
as crap
but uh yeah a little bit but now I have
to buy a new vehicle obviously Insurance
isn't going to give me near what the
vehicle is worth no they are just the
vehicle is worth exactly what they're
going to give you that's what the policy
says
uh we can and maybe my idea what the
vehicle's worth no your ideal Vehicles
I'm gonna talk about that the market
value of the vehicle they are legally
bound to give you the money for it right
and which means you can go buy another
vehicle exactly like you had for that
amount of money
and I guess that's where the question is
and I need help not to do something
emotionally you want to upgrade from the
wreck
oh well
I just I don't know if we need a truck
anymore and yes my son just bought a new
Cadillac CTS and then I'm looking at the
version of the CTS-V not a new one a
used one but I don't know if that's too
much money to spend on a car even if I
had the money do you have the money
I would be close depending on what
they're giving you the settlement on the
truck's not done yet okay rule number
one is if you don't have the money if
you don't have the money end of
discussion you don't buy it it's a
stupid car so you either got the money
or you don't buy the car number one
number two is is it too much car A good
rule of thumb is cars and things with
wheels and Motors of any kind go down in
value always
and so things with wheels and Motors
that you have in your possession in your
name should not total up more than half
your annual income otherwise you have
too much invested in things that go down
in value so what's the Cadillac cost
67. okay what do you make
135 household income
uh add another 22 so 127 157 what's
mama's car worth
Mama doesn't have a car there's a seven
1970 Camaro sitting in the garage
three quarters away restored so it's
your wife doesn't drive a car
we got
by like the truck was our only running
vehicle that okay I have a company car
that okay so the Camaro's worth what
um
in its present State probably 15. okay
so you can afford the 67 if you got the
cash
but if you don't have the cash you can't
do it
no upgrades due to wrecks to put you
into debt nope nope nope nope nope nope
and don't say things like it's gonna
make me make an emotional decision
you're gonna choose that that's a choice
don't make that choice yeah you've
already said it out loud so it's no
longer emotional now it's intellectual
that's
[Music]
the Ramsay show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney number one best-selling
author Ramsay personality and host of
the Dr John baloney show is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Elizabeth
starts us off in New Jersey this hour hi
Elizabeth welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you Mr Ramsey for having me
um I have a question I I am currently in
a situation towards I need to replace a
hot water heater I have a thousand
dollar savings uh in my emergency fund
and I'm on baby step two and I know you
advise people not to take advantage of
credit but I'm in a stuck situations
where I don't have the financial
resources to purchase a new one without
uh maybe utilizing
one of the finance options at my local
provider how much is the hot water
heater
two thousand eight hundred twenty three
dollars and Seventeen cents is the least
expensive I was able to
find I've contacted seven different
plumbing services and each one was much
more than that and one of my local big
box stores offered me that at that rate
and at a zero percent and I have a
thousand to contribute but I don't have
the other
two thousand dollars to put towards it
what happened to the hot water heater
it died
um it it's been in the house that I that
we I really recently required the house
last year and the hot water heater is
from 2004.
okay there's a lot of things that can
happen with a hot water heater this is a
tankless or a tank hot water heater
when the plumbers came out they
expressed on YouTube I need to place it
because it was leaking
and it was wasn't repairable
it's leaking
yes sir it let the small pond on the
kitchen floor
okay
um wow I haven't apparently been hot
water shopping in a while I had no idea
it was twenty eight hundred dollars to
put in a hot water heater that just
sounds outrageous to me
um I agree it was it was in truth it was
the least expensive one that I was able
to ask obtain quote from I was just
trying to I just put one in and it was
something somewhere similar okay it was
2000 so it was it was way more expensive
than I thought it was going to be I
remember being 2800 but it was a real
expense I just haven't bought one in a
while I guess that's my thing okay
um wow uh okay what do you make a year
I make about 98. and you have one
thousand dollars
yes sir okay and what else do you have
what other things do you have I have
I have student loan payments which are
995.55 cents a month they're on hold I
have
I'm still paying them sir because I know
I know but you have a hot water heater
in the South so it's on hold
yes sir okay I have a car payment which
like car payment is is
289 a month and I'm debt I only owe 1770
11.76 on that so it'll be paid off soon
and we have a few other credit card
debts which we're I'm working on paying
off and I don't use credit at all so
that's why I'm
in a predicament that I'm concerned as
to how to manage the situation yeah I
get that
um so uh what is your paycheck how often
do you get a paycheck and how much is it
bi-weekly and I make about uh two
thousand dollars every two weeks
that's what I take home
that's forty eight thousand dollars a
year how do you get forty eight thousand
dollars a year out of 90. hold on let me
let me double check I was mistaken I I
my paycheck is about I guess it's more
than that because I do make 98 000 on
paper but and I have nothing coming out
of my paycheck except for my insurances
my taxes
and yeah so your paycheck is more like
four thousand dollars every two weeks
yes sir probably yeah okay and so when
you get the next paycheck buy the hot
water heater
okay don't pay student loans put it on
hardship I mean drop it over there in
the Biden plan don't pay it for right
now you can pick it up and pay it's not
doodle May
right
okay
so what I'm going to do is just
rearrange your budget for a month and a
half or two months and
you know you're gonna have to push
something and then catch it back up and
pay cash for it
I think you've got the cash flow to buy
this in the next check
and maybe just food
right okay
I don't know I mean I I can't I can't
see your numbers right now but I mean
well
I I we have credit card debts which like
I said I'm paying all of them right now
don't pay them don't pay them for a
month
pay I'm late for a month okay
it's one month
or pay them I pay them at the end of the
month instead of the beginning of the
month or only pay the very very bare
minimums on all of them
and take that extra because you're
trying to keep baby step two going and
deal with this other thing yeah you
gotta you gotta push everything on pause
as far as baby steps go and um and you
gotta push everything you can push and
pay cash for this and then get back and
re-engage again
but um I've had to do that I've had to
shuffle and
just delay something to be able to cover
this and I think you can cover it inside
of a couple of weeks here but something
else that you thought was absolutely
vital is going to wait two more weeks
and it's not absolutely vital other than
food I mean keep your lights on in your
food and that's about it but even if you
paid your rent on the 15th instead of on
the first as an example
for this month and then get back in the
saddle and get caught right back up and
and you know it may take another month
to get uh back get things back even
again and then after that then push play
again start your start your dead
snowball but I think you've got enough
money coming in with your income because
you only need eighteen hundred dollars
um
and good for you for having shopped it
and gotten the best price
and just ask them what their payment
terms are I mean will they bill you at
the end of the month
if they put it in or do they want it all
up front or do they want a thousand
dollars now and eighteen hundred dollars
at the end of the month or whatever not
credit just a billing there's a
difference and just see what their
payment terms are there may be some
things like that because all we're
looking for here is a little bit of
movement a little bit of oomph to get
your cash flow flowing that's all we're
after here so Dave you've done this way
longer than me it sounds like if you
don't shut that door all the way
if you don't take
I can just go borrow this off the table
that you're gonna end up back in the
mess yeah you have to take borrowing
money off the table the rest of your
life I just took it off the table I
don't I don't borrow money so I've
always I've always had to do what we're
doing
is I gotta figure it out I gotta figure
it out because that's not or I gotta not
do it not doing hot water is not a fun
thing so and you know especially in
freaking New Jersey this time of year
you know good Lord in Tennessee this
time of year I don't want to be without
hot water but um
I mean everybody's talking about the
benefits of cold showers but this is not
the time to do it right so um yeah so
yeah uh no thank you not not as a
mandatory item
that needs to be a choice not for my
wife but it I do like you got to close
the door like I've got to take it off
the table otherwise you can have a thing
after a thing after it's always going to
be a thing always yeah so I'm even
wondering
where the hot water heater leaks yeah
you know like did it leak around the
element and the element is bad and
they're trying to you know I'm gonna buy
an element and seal that puppy if that's
it and that's a couple hundred bucks you
give me 30 more days or 16 more days
well or give me a year yeah you know but
now if the actual tank broke there's no
fixing that okay so the end yeah there
you go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones as we talk about your life and
your money it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five our question of the
day comes from Tony in the Ramsey Baby
Steps Community John you wanna read it
yeah you bet today's question is from
Tony says I'm having a hard time getting
my wife on board we have no Consumer
Debt just our house our emergency fund
is fully funded for a year we make
around three hundred and eleven thousand
dollars a year before taxes I've cut up
my credit cards but my wife doesn't want
to cut hers up she feels like she needs
them to she needs to have them for an
emergency what can I do to get her on
board and not argue about cutting her
cards up
so I'm looking at this this is not an
issue of this is not a math problem this
is not a rational approach problem over
the years how have you seen this play
out Dave
well I mean
the answer to your question is how do I
get her on board is complicated but her
actual statement is absolute horse crap
it's incorrect yeah I mean that's just
bull you don't need a credit card for an
emergency you make 311 000 you have a
fully funded emergency fund and no debt
that's just stupid you have a double
emergency fund no but that's not exactly
how you convert her okay wouldn't go at
it that way okay honey you're stupid hey
you're just stuck no that that's uh
that's ridiculous that that one never
worked for me so um let's try a
different attack
um so the thing is this
um
I always when any time I'm trying to get
anyone spouse included
on board with something I generally will
pan back and look further into the
future
instead of like this week I'm thinking
about credit cards I'm thinking about
what are the best
things that are in our life the what has
to be true about our life that gives us
or if these things were true about our
life they give us the best probability
of being
prosperous in our marriage and
prosperous financially
so 20 years from the day
if we're using credit cards as our
emergency backstop is that the most
likely way that we become prosperous or
if we got rid of them is that the most
likely way that we become prosperous
and so then that what that does is it
takes your hands off the wheel of the
moment the the the anxiety in the moment
um because what's happened here is she
remembers being broke
and so
I can tell you 30 years ago we filed
bankruptcy had our water cut off our
electricity cut off almost lost our home
had a brand new baby and a toddler and
uh if I
move towards a purchase of some kind 30
years later without my wife being
involved and agreeing that the idea is
within our budget and it's not going to
destroy us then that that pattern of
behavior that body language that I do
when I do that activates that's her
memory yeah it's a trauma response
that's right
she has a trauma response to it and so
she'll go you know she'll act like we
have absolutely no money and we have
hundreds of millions of dollars right
you know it's like oh God he's
got him you know it's like whoa whoa
whoa we were buying a box of gum here
that's Costco
it's like it's holy crap you know you're
out of control and it's like she doesn't
yell like that but her body does I can
watch her do that yeah and that I those
eyes get that fire in them you know and
all that is is she just is that that it
activates that Terror down inside of her
that she felt when she was a young mom
and didn't know if her kids are gonna
have food right and so that's why your
wife's not cutting up her car it's not
because of present-day circumstances but
because she remembers am I right yes and
I've also seen the more uh on on my show
here is there's a sense that
um and it's it's so far it's been
uniquely women but I it may go it may go
with men too
this idea that I need to hang on to
something in case he leaves
I'm going to hang on to some sort of
something and so I'm not hung out to dry
Here My Last Vestige of Independence
that's right and so I would ask Tony
something about their Dynamic at the end
of the day says she doesn't feel safe
could it be that she doesn't feel safe
what you're talking about because of
past she remembers being broke she
doesn't feel safe because there's
something about you husband who's making
a little different definition of an
emergency yeah like I I just need some
an escape hatch in case this thing goes
south yeah and so I if everything all
everything's safe
um around the board I love the idea of
hey would you commit to 30 days of
practicing can we put these in a drawer
somewhere over here let's think about
what gets us to this place we want to be
10 years from now yeah and then what are
those activities and then is there a way
we can babysit let's practice baby
practice into that and put them in the
drawer freeze them in the garage freeze
them in the block eyes use only debit
cards
um and then you go okay if we had an
emergency what could we rely on and in
the sense of being independent and are
safe like
you know after we had already were
millionaires again years later uh
Sharon's daddy sent her some money and
it wasn't a lot I mean 10 20 000 bucks
or something whatever it's nice nice
gift I mean he sent all his kids like
some money right it wasn't a wasn't life
changing but it was just a little pile
of money and she's like well what do we
do with this and I'm like well let's
just opened a mutual fund in your name
so it's got her name on it and my name
right but her name's first and that
there's something and it's like that's
her mutual fund and air quotes right
that we own right that her daddy gave us
you know and very nice little gift and
it's grown as many years ago it's turned
into some money you know over time but
um to this day if you go into my file
drawer it's like there's a little tab
Sharon's mutual fund huh you know and so
there's a sense of that and it's not
that we separated our finances or not
that I was worried about the legality of
it or not the shoes there's none of that
it was more of an emotional this is
yours yeah thing and it it again relax
that traumatized place in her spirit uh
that's that was legitimately try I mean
I'm not making fun of him she had every
right to be right that way and so our
emergency fund now has an emergency fund
for that reason I always want to go back
to that question
um and it's becoming more and more of a
question I ask myself and my wife and my
kid in my community
if you don't feel safe none of these
things I'm going to teach you are going
to matter because your body's going to
be off trying to make sure you don't die
in whatever weird way it's trying to do
that so how can I create safety and
there is a point when you can't hear it
you're choosing not to hear that you're
safe fine I can't I can't think about
that but man is there a way Tony yeah so
a couple of things here one is uh look
for the safety two is look long term
and then three is develop some steps of
practice
that that uh can cause her intellect to
rot into her emotions that you know you
you live okay we're living without this
oh we're living without it oh we can
live without it oh we're okay without it
and this word has been abused in our
culture but that Dave is mindfulness
that is all of a sudden she gets a
little bit her starts being a little bit
faster I need that credit card oh no I
don't right that's just having that
feeling thinking about it and then
letting it pass because I've got a debit
card in my wallet with a Year's worth of
salary in it we're good yeah I mean I
got a debit my debit card will do
everything your credit card will do
times probably two or three right well
yeah I mean because there's money in
there right and so yeah I can do I can
go just boss ridiculous something if I
you know subject to the Daily
limitations on the stupid thing or
whatever yeah maybe Tony maybe go get
her two debit cards from two different
banks and it's got each one of them's
got X number a thousand dollars in it
and yeah been that that's not to be
touched you know these are these are
debit cards we don't use because they're
tied to the emergency fund emergencies
and so and so they have the exact same
power
that if you wanted to drop 25 000 bucks
into credit card debt due to an
emergency instead we have 25 000 in this
account that's never going to be touched
and the debit card's in your wallet
right
how is that different mechanically it's
not right it's in Bay it's actually
better yeah
so yeah you've got to offset it and um
but here you know I will tell you Tony
that that I run into a lot of marriages
too and This falls under the heading of
feeling safe or being safe
um including mine
in the early days where uh she doesn't
feel like she has an equal vote
at the budget committee meeting
and if that and so she needs to hold
this in case uh in case you go crazy
because her vote doesn't count and so it
took a it took a while for Sharon and I
to get to where Sharon really felt her
vote was equal to mine on financial
decisions and on the budget committee
meeting monthly we're going to spend
money on this because you want to and I
don't want to nope
until we come into agreement we're not
doing it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
foreign
ly too much fun for talk radio this is
the Ramsey Show Dr John deloney Dave
Ramsey your host in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions which by the way you ought to
come by and visit us when you're in the
uh Franklin Tennessee Nashville
Tennessee area it's a free visit and uh
you can get to experience all of the
Ramsey Solutions things here including
free coffee and homemade cookies yeah
and the debt free screams happen right
here on the debt free stage every day
Charles and Emily are here welcome guys
hey how's it going better than I deserve
good to have you where do you live uh
Dalton Georgia oh just down the road
very good very cool welcome all right
how much debt of you two paid off about
97 000 sir all right and your rain how
long did this take you about two years
and ten months or 34 months got it okay
and your range of income in that 34
months uh started out about 36 000 and
uh We've Ended now at 105. whoa what do
you all do for a living uh well she's a
chemist and uh I'm a bi engineer so uh
now she's a stay-at-home mom so now it's
just on me okay and a b i yeah business
intelligence oh thank you dude the
Apparently I didn't have any so there
you go okay the way I filled that
acronym in my head was not a problem
okay I'm glad business intelligence well
obviously you were on either head one so
there we go now now we have him to help
us all right 97 000 bucks what kind of
debt uh our mortgage
oh so completely dead free now look I
wear weird people I love it I love it
what's this house worth about well now
it's about 180. uh we bought it a lot
cheaper than that one yeah so so uh how
long have you guys been married uh two
and a half years two and a half years
yeah also you started this before yeah
so I bought it right before we got
engaged we were already planning on
getting married
um so I bought a house that I was
comfortable with by myself but that
would be a great house for us to start a
family in yeah and so he said okay let's
do that and you get married and then you
dump both incomes on it yeah and knock
it out really really fast you had no
other debt uh no not besides that wow
yeah so Emily I'm assuming you were your
Chemistry job was carrying the load and
then you finally got off the couch
Charles well kind of when we got married
the day we came back from our honeymoon
she lost her job so that's actually just
me hearing no weight but uh a couple
months later she was able to find
another job we did that for uh I don't
know almost nine months probably nine
ten months something like that and then
uh we had our our son Jimmy where to go
guys very cool congratulations thank you
so what put you on this Ramsay track
getting your house paid off so uh my
parents were are have been following
Dave Ramsey for many years before this
um they paid off their house uh sometime
before and so you're a financial piece
baby I am I am and then uh Emily her
parents have always been fairly well
with money and then uh we got together
and we just said we need to pay off this
house let's get it done and change our
family tree I love it love it way to go
so they all got to be proud of you yeah
I think so all right I wonder if they
just no that's the expectation
a little bit of both they you know
there's expectation of you know being
wise with our money but also they're
they know you have to be on your own
path so yeah I'm being content I mean
you didn't go buy a half million dollar
house oh no no we we bought well within
our means yeah and something you could
knock out how old are you two I'm 25
she's 26. I'll be 27 Saturday oh 2017.
oh happy birthday good good he was
trying to help you out Emily she's a
little nervous so you're telling me
you're not even 30 yet y'all have a paid
off house yes sir that's unbelievable so
weird so awesome so proud of you very
very well done okay people listening are
going hey I don't know I mean how do you
do it what do you tell people the key is
uh diligence I think that is the biggest
key if you can continue to pay off every
month uh seeing those big numbers go
towards that even though you want to use
it for
anything that you travel whatever you
have to use it to pay off the debt and
uh if you do that you'll get it paid off
you just know the big numbers at it yeah
throw the big numbers at it even though
you really want to spend it you have to
be diligent and say we got to use this
for for debt and you know it's a lot of
money I want to ask you this question
and it's it's not meant to shame anybody
listening or anybody who's made their
choices okay I'm always
um fascinated by folks who
choose you chose 120 you say 130 000
house
worth 180. you qualified for the 300 000
house but you said this is this is
enough for us yeah how did you how'd you
land there how did you not get out of
school and say I'm a freaking chemist I
can do what I want and I'm marrying a bi
engineer
a big interesting engineer and I I'm
gonna like how did you not how did y'all
decide on that
honestly over the years my parents have
lived in three homes since they've been
married and they made gradual steps as
they they had a small house when they
were married then they moved to a
slightly larger house when they had us
and then a slightly larger house when
they had my third sibling
um and so I figured hey that's a great
way to not be in a lot of debt and just
slowly make our way up as so contentment
as our family value yeah 100 but it's
very common for 25 year olds to come
running out of the gate and want to live
in the same house that Mom and Dad live
in right now after 20 or 30 years and
that's that's that's that
self-discipline is incredible it's going
to set you up over the long term in a
pretty amazing way yeah that's an
emotional maturity that's very very cool
to watch congratulations thank you
you're gonna be you're gonna be so
wealthy I mean unbelievable you're
making a hundred thousand bucks she's a
she's a full-time mom you got a paid for
house and you're 25 freaking years old
oh my God you're gonna miss so many fun
fights that me and Dave got to have
yeah well now we gotta we gotta figure
out what to do with the money and use it
for God's to further his kingdom yeah
for sure so what for what's your first
big thing you want to do with money now
that you're out of debt houses we're
planning to go on a trip to Switzerland
and uh maybe potentially Israel so that
will be a pretty expensive uh little
vacation to go on that is a great run
both of those are great trips I highly
suggest both of them I've done them both
and I'll go back to Switzerland and I'll
go back to Israel someday but uh we've
been there three times but uh but yeah
Switzerland's a great trip yes do it
that's awesome man way to go you live
like nobody else later you get to travel
like nobody else I like it yes sir very
cool good for y'all well done and you
brought the baby along name and age
Jamie he is about four months oh yeah
okay well we may scare him with a dead
friend that's okay maybe he'll join us
not voluntarily I'll tell you okay good
good way to go you guys hey we got the
live and give bundle for you that
includes The Total Money Makeover book
it includes the baby steps millionaires
book which you are well on your way to
being
and of course Financial Peace University
membership and so use those give them
away either one it is the live and give
bundle way to our way of saying thank
you for coming all the way up here from
Dalton Georgia to do your debt free
screen
Charles and Emily and Jamie
get free house and everything at 25
freaking years old so any of you whiners
out there we just just put this up there
for you just for just to show you that
this can be done you guys are mic
dropping this is awesome very very proud
of you 97 000 paid off house and
everything 34 months making 36 000 up to
105. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're debt
free
[Applause]
this is how it's done
man I love it I love it I love it well
done you two very well done so that's a
second generation over there yes I'm
just I'm just laughing like it's the
exact opposite of what I did Dave I had
some debt coming out of college and I
drove a little tiny Tercel easy
hatchback it was just like a human
roller skate and I thought I need the
biggest truck I can possibly buy I got
my first job making good money and I
ended up that year more in debt than
when I started and had to buy the
biggest this then I support I just did
the exact opposite and I just think what
a it took me a decade to dig out of that
hole that they never made they never
made because of contentment they were
just contentment as a family value
amazing and uh lack of hours on
Instagram adds to Contender I'll just
tell you you're not watching other
people's highlight reels that are of a
life that they don't really have and uh
and then other buddies who celebrate you
and aren't always hassling about are you
driving that they're like no like he's
just got different values or he's done
different dreams and or whatever yeah
he's gonna be rich yeah it's amazing
guys Wow way to go very cool great job
you guys as your Heroes very very proud
of you Dr John deloney Ramsay
personality you can join him daily
weekly on the Dr John deloney show as a
podcast be sure and check it out it's
unbelievably popular he's my co-host
today here on the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America this is the
Ramsay show paying off debt is smart
saving and investing is what you can do
when you don't have any payments and
that's smart
there's one key to winning with money
that people Overlook all the time though
and that's protecting your finances from
catastrophes emergencies this is where
insurance comes to play
now there are 10 kinds of insurance
coverage that you might need based on
what your life looks like today and
we've built a tool called the coverage
checkup to show you which types you need
to add drop or adjust and we'll even
rank your coverage list by importance
email it to you and connect you with
Ramsay trusted insurance providers so
you can get your plan in place seriously
it could be the most important five
minutes you spend today it's completely
free visit ramsaysolutions.com checkup
that's ramseysolutions.com checkup don't
let an emergency sneak up on you because
you didn't do your checkup Chase see
what I did there all right Libby is with
us Libby's in Austin Texas hi Libby
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up I have an inheritance question
for you today
my husband and I are a military family
and baby step six should we use the
inheritance money we've recently
received plus our emergency fund to pay
off our 15-year 2.5 mortgage or save it
towards our next home the military is
going to move us across the country this
fall
doesn't matter
between now and fall you're not going to
make any money on the money anyway
you can park it in your house by paying
it off or you can park it in a savings
account neither one are going to pay you
anything
and if you move in the fall and you sell
your house and you paid off the house
you get the money out right
and if you're moving the fall and you
didn't pay off your house you'll get the
money out of the house and when you sell
it and you'll take all the money from
savings and buy the next house right
right the trick is for sure pay cash for
the next one
okay that part might be a little bit
hard because we'll use up all of our
funds that we would have to build back
up so we'd have to rent where we go no
I'm sorry why would you use Apollo wait
a minute
you have enough to pay off your current
home if you were to stay there but
you're not staying there
what's your current home worth
about 300 000. okay where are you moving
moving to Seattle
okay
yeah 200 a little tougher there than uh
Austin Texas but you did it in Austin
Texas
it's not substantially different than
Seattle
so if you could live in a 200 000 house
in Austin I'm saying you probably could
live in one in Seattle
okay uh that makes sense so I'm just
saying
it you should end up in a paid for house
on the other end that's the plan thanks
for your service we appreciate you guys
loading up the stuff and moving around
to make sure our country is protected
thank you for doing all that so Dave I'm
gonna ask a question as though I was a
listener to the show because it just
popped into my head is there any
is there a length of time before I park
it in my house
all right let me ask you this way I
would be concerned the value of my house
goes down between now and x and of
course your house value is not affected
by your mortgage
but if I pay okay that's fair
yeah you're right I'm paying it off
doesn't cause it to go down or up gotcha
it just goes up or down and um so if it
goes down you just have less money when
you sell it out of equity or you have
less money because you paid it off but
you're still getting back that money you
just put in it either one yeah you'll
get it all back and then it's just a
matter of you maybe some of your
value increase your appreciation is
going to go backward but I don't think
it will it might go back a little but
I don't think it's gonna be that big a
deal Zack's in San Francisco hey Zach
what's up
hi
um I'm in baby step 3D 3B with my wife
and with the stock market down
we're wondering if we should slow down
baby step 3B and invest a little bit
more or if we should continue on at the
same rate that we've been taking how
much are you putting in of your income
into retirement
well no it's about eight or nine percent
okay
all right and so you want to uh invest
more into your retirement rather than
save more towards your house
right pushing it more up towards 15
um versus saving the eight or nine
percent
okay
so you're going to delay buying your
home in order to do this
so we already it would it wouldn't be
delaying buying the home so much as not
having as big a down payment we already
have uh what our goal is over 50 of our
down payment it would just be whether we
have 55 or 65 percent let's see okay
yeah that's fine
that's fine here's the thing it's within
the guidelines of what we teach what I
don't
ever want to encourage too much
is let's say that you're already putting
15 into your retirement and you said hey
I want to bump that up to 20.
and in other words violate what we teach
and you know put more in than we would
tell you to do because the market now
you're pushing to time the market now so
timing the market I love that you're a
contrarian you're going to always make
money doing that but timing the market
and saying I want to buy while it's down
I want to buy when it's down that makes
you want to sell when it's up and no
we're not doing any of that we're just
going to buy and keep buying keep buying
keep buying keep buying keep buying keep
buying keep 15 of your income and baby
step four regardless of the markets up
or down goes into retirement when you're
at baby step four if you want to do that
whole 15 put a little less down on your
house that's okay that's within the
guidelines
but avoid this
chasing returns it's called in the
research
people who chase returns by trying to
figure out and time the market uh very
seldom do as well as those of us that
just constantly invest so again what
you're doing is under the constantly
invest headline so we're going to go
with it but the reason you're asking the
question
I'm not going to go with
which is timing the market don't try to
time the market that's always a bad bad
place to go
that makes sense hope it does open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Ethan is in Michigan
hi Ethan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so I am in baby step one I just
completed it I only have about seven
thousand dollars in debt that should be
paid off mid-july and my question is I'm
thinking about buying a home in the next
two to three years good well I don't
know where closing costs fit in if I
should combine them with my down payment
or they should be separate
so you're talking about the total
um like you're gonna buy a hundred
thousand dollar house and it's going to
have X number of there's no such thing
as a hundred thousand dollar house
anymore a 200 000 house and there's
gonna be some closing costs associated
with it
yes
yeah
um so your closing costs are just part
of your down payment yeah it's a big
it's a whole picture it all falls the
same bucket like you said Ethan so yeah
it's just so when you're working on your
baby step 3B you've probably heard us
talk about we're talking about with the
last caller which means you're out of
debt you have your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses in place
then
that's when you start saving for your
down payment maybe before you start
retirement in the last caller's case he
was putting in eight percent towards
retirement was going to kick it on up to
15 and save a little less but anyway
that's the point at which you're saving
for your down payment that's also the
point in the same bucket that you're
going to take that money out of to cover
closing costs and down payments that
make sense
yes how would I calculate it I've seen
so many videos on different ways to
calculate it but I hear it's I I find it
really hard to calculate how much I
should save
uh all you can and quit watching those
videos
um they're gonna make you crazy yeah
because a bunch of them have an agenda
and they're trying to push something or
they're trying to push some weird crap
that's flying around the internet so
you're better off just to sit down with
a good real estate agent go to Ramsey
when you're ready ramsaysolutions.com
click on uh ELP for real estates Ramsay
trusted people the people that are
absolute Pros that do a ton of deals and
they can sit down and start telling you
how closing costs will work what you're
going to want to look for is a
conventional mortgage FHA and VA are
both more expensive interest rate and
more expensive fees show your cheapest
loan is a conventional Fannie Mae loan
and
you want to save up as much as you can
save up there and then a good real
estate agent can walk you through what
your actual closing costs are going to
be and you really don't you know I
really would not use YouTube for my
source on that and I'm sure it's crap
wouldn't use Tic Tac for my source on
that so be careful with these videos
um now get with a good real estate Pro
and they can walk you right through it
it's really not rocket surgery you can
figure it out you'll be able to do it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show but we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsay personality and host of
the Dr John deloney show is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five David is in
Jefferson New Jersey hi David welcome to
the Ramsay show
hello gentlemen how are you today better
than we deserve sir how may we help
well
I ordered the Financial Peace University
at your Christmas special thank you very
much
um and we started on that in January and
we basically been tearing into our debt
good we basically paid off around 50 000
worth and I said you paid off 50 000 in
one month
no we started in January we started
paying in October but we went to
Financial Peace started in January and
you paid off fifty thousand dollars
yes since October wow I sold a boat
if it wasn't nailed down it was going
out the door wow that's awesome David
yeah well my problem is I got 1200 left
on One credit card which if I have a
good week of side hustles I'm gonna pay
that off this week and for the first
time in my life I'll not have a credit
card bill whatsoever why'd it go man
yeah you got it buddy watching these
things go to zero has just been a thrill
for me and my wife good for you my
problems my problem is coming up I've
got a get sixteen thousand dollars it's
a 401k loan it has to be paid in full I
can't make payments so I don't
it's been so long since I saved money
I'm just not sure how to save that
because the debt behind that is 21
000 on my wife's truck and I know I can
go after that and mash that thing down
to zero and then come back and save for
the other one I would so I'm just
motivationally how do I is there is
there a trick no I think I think here I
think you're under something I'd
probably skip the 401K and Roll It on
behind it what other is that your only
two debts left
that's it okay good should we knock out
the truck then we gotta shave up and do
it right
yeah very good
okay that's it that's what I'm going to
do because I was worried because my
behavior has not been saving it's been
spending right but you're you're on a
you're on a you've got a momentum right
now and I don't want to do anything a
trip set up
so knock that truck out just knock it
out how quick You're Gonna Knock that
truck out
um
let's see 21 000.
four months yeah yeah and and then in
three months more you'll have the money
saved to knock out the 401.
yeah if you want to be clever about it
David and I find myself trying to be
clever which is always gets me in
trouble but uh you may go down to your
or just go to your online bank and open
up an account and make a payment into it
while you're saving that eighteen
thousand
yeah when you get to the 401K just pay
yourself payments in a separate account
John's saying
gotcha and that that feels like you're
paying it down right
yeah it's just it's getting higher
versus lower but that's okay it's going
to get to zero sooner or later well the
point is the point is either way by
September we're done
no doubt no what it's gone by then and
for the first time in your life you're
going to be completely free
I will be I'm so proud of you mortgage
we'll have a mortgage I'm 64 looking at
retirement we're going to knock the
mortgage out next maybe three four years
keeps going so if anybody uh
if anybody says is it too late for me
I'm just going to tell them look up
David in Jefferson New Jersey because it
ain't too late for him
you're getting it buddy you're getting
it I love you
thank you thank you appreciate the call
man well done it's awesome
it's awesome it is so easy to fall into
a trap of I'm stuck and I can't get it
instead he's just like up on top of it
whipping it through it or I'm too young
or I'm too old or I'm too man get after
it you're not two whatever it is all
right get it get it Bust It Brett is
with us Brett is in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Brett welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave hey John thanks for taking my
call today I really appreciate you both
sure how can we help
so I'm in a unique situation my wife and
I are both 39 years old uh we're debt
free with the exception of our mortgage
and a small renovation loan that we just
finished up here in Hickory North
Carolina right outside of Charlotte
um we did get a 15-year we renovated
renovated an old property uh with a 15
year and got a very low interest rate uh
with the exception of owning owing about
239 000 we have an investment property
in the Smoky Mountains that kind of hold
it and self-manage it as a vacation
rental for the last five years uh what
kind of in a unique spot where given the
increase in value properties in the
Smokies
uh we're looking at considering selling
it and why don't you get your thoughts
we do have a second child on the way in
September uh we have a toddler now who's
two about to be two here in a few days
um and we really want to focus our time
on family and uh we're afraid that the
investment property is turned more into
uh taking away the value of our life in
terms of what we want to do with our
time uh instead of looking at as as a
future investment for us you know for
retirement so how much money would you
lend on the kitchen table if you sold it
and as it says right now we bought it a
downtime in the Smokies after a fire
which was you know a good time for us
then we would probably pocket around
about 350 to 375. okay
and so a good way to analyze these
things is just visualize 350 000 stacked
up in the middle of your kitchen table
and you don't own the property in the
Smokies
would you go would you go buy that
property
probably not
okay whatever the problems whatever the
probably is needs to be discussed but if
you went absolutely not then that tells
you you absolutely sell it right
so it sounds like you're probably
selling it so whatever was calling to
you to say probably
I guess still needs to be considered but
sure what's keeping you from pulling the
trigger man
is it the idea of being a like a like
having multiple Properties or you
watched a lot of property brothers and
you're like what what's the thing
yeah good question John
um and that's part of it man I think
there's some emotion tied to the
property
um it was our home for a little while uh
we actually became debt free because we
were full-time rvers for three years uh
we put our house up for rent in
Nashville which we later sold uh and
took the net proceeds from that sale
when I turned into renovation of this
whole historic property
um basically what happened but during
that time we were rving it was our home
base uh so anytime we we needed to
collectively kind of
if you will as they say that was then
this is now
correct yes sir now you're not an RV or
now you have a baby and now you have a
mortgage unchain yourself man and cut
this thing loose pay off your mortgage
yeah
and then and then start saving for your
future Investments maybe what sounds fun
you've done well with real estate you
may want to buy some more but save up
and pay cash for it after your home is
paid for and uh thank you to the Smokies
it did as well this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today hey tickets are going fast for our
Building Wealth live tour just four more
stops on the tour guys you don't want to
miss this you want to get control of
your money I am going to be live in your
city if you're in one of these four
cities along with the team I'll be next
week February 16th you can catch me in
Indianapolis with Rachel Cruz George
Campbell and Jade warshaw the following
week February 23rd
did I say April 16th was February 16
next week April or February 23rd I'll be
with Ken Coleman Dr John deloney and
Jade warshaw in Austin Texas on April
24th we'll be in Salt Lake City with
Rachel Cruz George Campbell and
Christina Ellis and our final stop of
the tour is Anaheim I'll be there May
2nd with Ken Coleman Dr John deloney and
Christina Ellis tickets are only 49
dollars
and you can get a four pack of tickets
starting at only 175 so hurry don't miss
your chance to see me and the Ramsey
Personalities in person we'll sign books
uh take pictures answer questions we're
going to have a blast you don't want to
miss this go to ramsesolutions.com
events and get your seats now these
things do sell out early Austin Texas
just about gone and indy is uh I mean
there's like 100 tickets left for Indy
so get tickets now if you want to come
we'd love to have you Zeke is where the
seek is in Minneapolis hi Zeke welcome
to the Ramsay show what's up
hey thank you Dave how you doing today
better than I deserve how can I help
hey thank you uh me and my wife are
going over our expenses last night and
got a little uh anyway upset over how
much we were spending so we decided
we're gonna knock this last bit of debt
out we get with my bonus so I'm getting
from work
and then we'll be clear on the baby step
three
great problem is that right after that
happened found out that I am eventually
going to be laid off what does
eventually mean and
we may tell me when I'm being told I
will be laid off well I mean what do you
think is this a day a week a year
could be a couple months and but what I
do know is that after that I will have
60 days of notice in which I'll continue
to get paid
and after that 60 days of notice
I'll be getting 14 to 16 weeks of
severance pay awesome
now what do you make if I oh thank you
sir I make just my regular salary is 95.
what do you do
I'm an analytic consultant oh great
awesome yeah thank you okay so your
income's getting ready to go up and
you're going to get a new better job huh
that is yes absolutely yeah I mean you
weren't looking but they just told you
to
yes yes sir
so you need to land a job just in time
to get that big severance check
indeed that'd be great that's like a
signing bonus then right
yeah it would be for me yeah
um
but I figured that
in the worst case scenario and just not
my goal at all but even at the end of
the severance
should be able to put the if I paid off
the debt immediately
uh still have a six months
uh expensive savings after the end of
the severance
you're going to get a job
I know thank you no I mean really
There's jobs everywhere there's more
jobs than there I mean there's more jobs
than there are people looking for jobs
so I mean you got this is you're in
really good shape
thank you this is the best time to get
laid off
okay all right thank you for the support
no I'm I'm not making this up I mean
this is not support I'm I'm glad if you
were screwed Dave would tell you it also
happens to be the truth so you know
I don't know I don't know if you're in
Minneapolis at the end of the story or
not what's your wife work what she make
all my life is unemployed we I'm the
head host okay that's cool all right
well you're in a field of analytics data
management uh and so on that is hot hot
very few companies are going to exist if
they don't invest in your area over the
coming five years companies of size
anyway and so the the you are your
position is I mean it's deeply needed I
got I got three of those type things on
the board right here at Ramsey right now
so up I mean up for sale right now we're
trying to hire people so
um
uh data is just and analytics are just
if you can't do that in the future world
you're not going to be open and so
you're just you're sitting in a Sweet
Spot man and seriously you might roll
into 120 and pocket the severance as
your signing bonus you really might
I want you to start looking and I want
you to use everything Ken Coleman's got
have you heard of Ken have you heard
Ken's stuff yet
so uh to be fair uh honest you hired one
of my managers a couple years ago and
he's the greatest guy and
congratulations on you for hiring them
I don't know if I can say his name but
uh anyway he sent me a link to Ken
Coleman's uh
cool 150 questions who are you talking
about
Elliot Chambers oh God he's great you're
right yeah yeah that's awesome cool yeah
that's how that's amazing
yeah so what you mean get get kids stuff
get the resume stuff I'll send you a
copy of paycheck to purpose Ken's book I
want you to read that and so here's the
thing I was just talking with a young
guy this morning that uh in this
mentoring session thing I was in and he
was like okay how do you get security if
you're working contract and I said
everybody's on contract baby
because you're a guy nobody's got
security except for your ability land on
your feet when they kick you out and you
got so much ability to land on your feet
that your security comes from your
ability not your stupid company
and that's why you're just in a Sweet
Spot man you're just you're rocking and
this is going to turn out so good if
you'll plan it just a little bit Yeah
and know this
um if you're like me like most men we
put a lot of our self-worth into our job
and when somebody says hey we don't want
you to work for our company anymore it's
a it's a it's a gut punch
Ken and I have looked at some data
together where it losing your job
somebody calling you in and saying
you're fired
responds in your body as though you lost
a loved one
so it's like you're not crazy and you're
not weak you're not a wimp you're not a
whiny baby like it hurts man when
somebody calls and says hey you're fired
and it sets off a terror alarm on our
body it should and then you get to fall
back on the data like Dave's telling me
here's what here's what's worse they
didn't even tell you that they said
we're going to tell you that later but
we don't know when yeah it's like dating
somebody and they're like I love you I'm
gonna break up with you later
I don't know when
yeah so I mean it's Terror they just
hung you out to dry but hey there you
know at least they dangled the carrot of
the severance to get you to stick around
a little while opportunity opportunity
opportunity Man by the way if you get a
really big signing bonus tomorrow and
120 000 uh just pack your desk and go
forget this average
I understood okay yeah so start looking
I'll send you a paycheck to purpose if
you can line it up for your start date
to be about the time they announce at
the new place
and unless there's enough money to leave
early uh you can get the severance as
your signing bonus out the door that's
going to be
freaking fun right there so yeah you see
you're in good shape yeah go ahead and
use your bonus money pay off your debt
money for your emergency fund you got a
big old pile for an emergency fund and
you got the severance in the background
and you got Ken Coleman on your team
getting you moving thanks to Elliot and
man you got all the stuff you got all
the stuff I know how to do and so you're
you know you got your resume template
you've got uh you're going to start
using your proximity principle people
you know who how can you get connected
to get your foot in the door on this and
Ken's going to teach you every bit of
that and you're going to land a job in
no time
your only problem might be that you
landed too soon and you you have to get
the quandary of whether to stick around
long enough to get the severance and uh
that might be a hard decision actually
so but just keep looking get out there
get moving hang on we'll uh have the
guys pick up and give you a copy of that
book and get you moving wow
congratulations on your freedom Zeke
yeah one of the very few shows you'll
call and someone says I'm getting laid
off and we go yes good
good because you're not being paid
enough this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John deloney show is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey if you're new
to this whole Ramsey process and you
hear us using this lingo on here that
kind of feels like it's inside baseball
like you have to know all the stuff to
be able to do the stuff it's really not
that complicated but yeah we kind of
have developed our own tribe speak so to
speak and if you want to know a little
bit more and here's what you can do you
want to dig deeper into the Ramsay baby
steps as an example go to
ramseysolutions.com click on the get
started button and we'll help you figure
out the next best step for your your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you are today it's completely free
click get started and we'll walk you
through the whole process at
ramsaysolutions.com get started it
doesn't cost a thing and it'll kind of
get you you know into the lingo and
you'll get you know you'll get caught up
here because sometimes listening to the
show is like what are they talking about
well I mean you have to be careful we we
overdo that sometimes but
this will at least get you moving in the
right direction Gabriel is with us in
Fort Lauderdale hi Gabriel welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey Dave hey John how you doing today
better than we deserve what's up
so long story short I'm working my debt
snowball and baby step two right now and
I'm returning to a job that I love so
much in school security but
unfortunately I'm expecting a minor pay
cut
so my question to you is have I
officially uh effectively budget my
money and find a side hustle that pays a
decent amount of money for me to be able
to kind of survive down here in South
Florida why in the world
are they cutting the pay of school
security officers
yeah I am not sure why I was working in
the charter school segment Which is
higher paying but unfortunately they
always dropped a contract they give it
to an agency for a cheaper amount so I
just went ahead and returned to the
public school board in my local County
have you thought about
um just going to the academy I don't
know a police department in the country
that's not looking for people
I did I applied over the summer when I
found out that they dropped my contract
and I was in the process of doing it
when a new opportunity with training
dogs came around and I thought it'd be
kind of unique and different so I wanted
to explore it but after about six months
of doing it it's uh it's not my thing so
I want to return back to Public Safety
so can you can you call back the
recruiting officer and get back involved
yeah I absolutely could it's just that
working directly into schools kind of
something that interests me a little bit
more than you know being out on the road
as a police officer uh they're
completely different jobs but uh yeah I
get that I mean I've I I've had school
um police departments reporting of
through me at my at various universities
what I'm saying is I get that those are
different jobs I'm trying to figure out
is there a similar enough-ish job that
doesn't require you to make nothing yeah
to take Cuts in pay
in an economy where people are dying to
hire people
I mean there's yeah the hiring people
are paying unbelievable money for all
kinds of positions out there right now
and so
um you know I
I don't want you to be as stuck as you
feel like you are right
I think you could find similar
gratification if you adjusted three
clicks to the left or right and moved
into something that paid double what
you're being paid
um I appreciate you want to sacrifice
and be there for the kids that's awesome
um but they're making it untenable for
you let me paint you this picture my dad
was a police officer growing up and he
mowed lawns on the weekend and he
cleaned the church he was the janitor
for a season
and he would go help another like so
that's the life
that's the choice right that's a tough
road to hoe especially with so many jobs
out there and I dude it's in my blood I
love it I love everything about it
that's that's my community it's tough
and I just can't rub my I'm having
trouble even wrapping my head around how
they would drop the the contract right
now just Madness it's just Madness
um in a season when we need to be paying
school security officers more to get
more people and more qualified
applicants to drop at his Madness but
that's where we find ourselves it is
what it is you gotta deal with reality
um
ah
I don't know man so yeah I think that in
that world of
serving and protecting there's a lot of
things that fall in that bucket that
would scratch the itch uh that you could
either add to this position as an
additional thing or uh or make a change
in that direction and either one would
help you with your income side of the
equation so you can work the door at a
restaurant or a club at night my dad
used to work concerts on the weekends
and in the evenings for extra money
baseball games that look I mean all
kinds of side hustle jobs here and there
if that's what you want to do that are
security oriented that's right yeah yeah
then there's
my guess is there's a ton of that out
there uh you just get to poking around
in that world get get in a couple of
those little circles Circles of people
that that line you up on it John is with
us John is in Concord New Hampshire hi
John welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave and John how are you guys great
man what's up
well uh my wife and I are in baby step
six and we're kind of lead to the game
with the life insurance thing and I've
been presented an option where
there is a term policy that can convert
into whole life as an investment vehicle
how would you want to do with your
opinion on that
it was presented to us and I really
don't know a lot about it oh okay all
right over
oh and um
I'm sorry and um
we'll be we'll have the house paid off
here in the next few years so if we did
a short term and then started converting
is what this person was telling us yeah
we could use it as an investment vehicle
and they paid dividends to us and I
don't understand that I just didn't know
what your opinion was okay so this is uh
what Northwestern Mutual New York Life
New York Life yes yeah okay because
they're about the only ones selling that
crap anymore it's one of the worst
Financial products on the planet
not only is the term insurance that they
price to you way too expensive but then
they're trying to convert you into an
absolute screw job which is an
investment inside of a life insurance
policy you're much better off just to
buy term life insurance do your
investing anywhere except New York Life
or Northwestern Mutual
gross wow okay yeah horrible horrible
remember that time you called Dave Des
for his opinion yeah and that anyway he
wasn't clear
um so now let me back up let me back up
and tell you the detail okay you want to
hear the detail on I'll give it to you
okay a couple things one is there's two
types of life insurance companies that's
how I knew who this was okay there's
Mutual or stock
stock companies are owned by the
stockholders Mutual companies are owned
by the policyholders
So when you buy a policy with New York
Life you're one of the owners
of New York Life
okay
with me
the same thing with uh State Farm
they're a mutual company okay now here's
the way dividends work in life insurance
follow me here you're the owner of the
company so if you own a company and it
makes a profit and they distribute that
profit to the owners of the company
that's called the dividend distribution
does that make sense
yes so if you opened up a company or you
bought stock in Home Depot and Home
Depot made a profit they would
distribute that profit that's called a
dividend
all right so in a mutual company they
are talking about Distributing the
profits of the company that you own to
you
you follow me that's your dividends you
with me so far
I am okay now where do profits come from
the customers
buying things
that have profit margin
and so you as a customer are giving New
York life so much money
that they're going to make a profit and
give some of it to the owner back to you
okay this is a dog chasing its tail
sounds like a glorified essential oil
scheme yeah and so
the IRS has ruled that a
life insurance dividend is not taxable
income because it is the re here's the
IRS language it is the refund of a
deliberate overcharge
that's the irs's lingo run
run to xanderinsurance.com get you an
inexpensive term life insurance policy
good God I get dividends yeah it's a
refund of a deliberate overcharge it's
kind of like saying I got a refund from
the IRS and I'm making a profit no it
was your money you overpaid the IRS
that's why they gave it back to you it's
the exact same thing and that's not
taxable either by the way this is the
Ramsay show
thank you
foreign
[Music]
14 23 there is profit and hard work
but mere talk leads to poverty
hmm
Dr Samuel dubo
cook the first African-American
professor at Duke University said have a
vision of Excellence a dream of success
and work like hell
it's almost like that conversation we
had at the very beginning of the very
first hour all came full circle man yeah
there it is right there there is profit
and hard work but mere talk leads to
poverty and sit down and dream think
about what could be and then go get it
I mean get after it it's hard it's awful
and scrape Knuckles and it's exhausting
and it's tiring you get hurt and all if
you're a a young man out there in your
20s and you're single
um I want you to work
so hard
that you will be very attractive
to that young lady's father
well that got weird Dave no I mean he
will think you are a stud and welcome
you to date his daughter that's what I
mean gotcha I don't mean
you weirdo but the I'm talking about you
seriously I mean I was watching the
newscaster and they're like you know
seven million men aged 25 to 54 that are
able-bodied won't work they are not
looking for work and the lady newscaster
said before she even thought she went
she said well that's not that's not
attractive wow you know it is it is
unattractive makes you ineligible to the
opposite that's a common question how do
I get someone to like date me to like me
what just make yourself the best version
of yourself yeah like be excellent be
getting it all right Neil is with us
Neil's in Minneapolis hi Neil welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you uh I mean that sincerely
you got it every time what's up sure
what's up the scenario that I'm
encountering at them so I have I'm fully
I'm fully employed on the side what I
like to do is make sure I kind of give
back to my community so I volunteer with
the fire departments I'm a fire medic
um over the last year we've had a number
of really traumatic scenes in my area
with children passing cool and so what
has happened is
um I'm carrying that and I'm carrying
that charm and I come back home and I
have my my children I have four uh who
want some things what they want to go to
Disneyland so I'll simply just folks
that trip and we went
um because I always have that that fear
that I'm going to miss it if something
does happen with my kids yeah and so I
guess my question is
um and I'm begging for some help here
um How do I
how do I get past that I I I don't know
if I can't call wasteful spending
um probably is let me tell you this let
me take you I've been there
I ran scenes and I saw things in homes
and I saw things in the street with kids
that I will that will haunt me until I'm
no longer on this Earth
yeah and then I'd go home there was two
nights I I know in particular that I
went and went into my son's room and
hugged him while he was asleep
I've been there yeah there's times that
I saw my daughter walk out that next
morning with her hair all a wreck and
she's kind of waddling through because
she was real young and I just started
crying
okay I get it
and you have to know this this truth you
got to embed it in your soul your kids
don't want your stuff they want you
I feel like this time together like
that's that's what I'm trying to create
at that moment
it doesn't have to be a Disney it's not
a moment brother you can go sit in a mud
puddle in your backyard with your
daughter and y'all let her put a hose
over your head and she'll tell that
story at your funeral
what you're doing is you're creating a
space
between the trauma you saw and
experience secondarily they call it
vicarious trauma and your own kids
you're trying to create a distance and
you're using Disney as the distance
you're using a buying a bunch of stuff
is the distance and you can't man
they're gonna feel that Gap Brothers
they're going to chase out their whole
lives go sit in the mud with them and
say hey I love you and I miss you go on
a hike
t-i-m-e does not cost money
it's hard yeah
what you have to be able to do in grasp
which is really challenging for a first
responder
is two two paradox I mean it's a paradox
but two opposing sides
you have to hold in your hand something
you get to see a part of the world that
you don't that nobody else gets to see
this could actually happen
and then you have to also be honest and
hold on the other hand but it probably
won't
and that's attention that a first
responder's got to live in and if you if
you hit the teeter-totter too much on
either side then you call it Causes
Chaos so it's it could happen here like
I'm there it could happen
but it's probably not so I'm gonna go me
and my kids we're gonna go fishing and
you know we're not gonna catch anything
and I'm gonna spend all my time
uncluttering lines and then we're going
to get chicken nuggets or whatever
nonsense we're gonna do time
and I'm gonna have to look at them and
say every moment's precious and holy
because it is
way more
I just feel like I I just I don't know
if it's a compulsion I don't know if
it's there's definitely something that's
changed psychologically it's a trauma
response that's right and you if you
want to be an actual Brave responder you
need to go talk to somebody
and I understand if you don't trust your
system go call a local therapist Newtown
hey Neil listen I went crazy no no I win
listen to me I went mad and my wife paid
the price for it
now don't do that go talk to somebody
yeah this is this it's it's a post
traumatic
stress reaction
that they they have a name for it right
I mean because you're seeing stuff that
that is acid being thrown into your
brain
and uh it's very brave and courageous to
do that uh but then your brain starts
saying this is going to happen to your
kids and statistically we know it's not
right
right and holding that balance and then
not reacting and but what you're doing
is a perfectly normal response
to a horrible situation
that your brain is in right um I mean
you're not crazy this is just a normal
as a matter of fact the fact that you
recognized it means you're way ahead of
the game if you called me and said hey
I'm not having any problems and all my
friends are I would say yeah you just
need to go talk to somebody now right
that would tell me you're not
functioning right the fact it's not it's
not it's not normal for human eyes to
observe the things you've observed
that's right
in the mass that you've had it happen
I mean most people might see something
like you saw once in their life and
you've seen it three times last week
am I wrong that's 100 can I tell you
this Neil um and this because of your
position and role it may not be possible
you also have to know when enough is
enough
volunteer position I I broke the
Cardinal code one time I walked into a
situation and there was a small child
and I looked at my partner and I said
I'm out and her name is Patrice she's
amazing I said I'm out and she said you
can't leave me here and I said I can't
because I had an 18 month old daughter
at home and we talked about it later and
I was wrong and I said I was sorry and
she said no no no no I'm with you that's
why they send two of us and so if
there's moments when you get a call out
and you know I I can't today have the
courage to say I can't today
I just fear that off
I don't know it's not easy for me to do
that it's not easy for me to reach out
I'm the guy that people call for help
yep not the guy that goes looking for it
I uh I fear that some of the stuff I
against some of the I don't know these
vacations this financial damage is
already kind of done
I gotta kind of build out of it which
well you gotta you gotta dig out of that
because that was a mistake
yeah I mean it's a good reason to make a
mistake a noble reason to make a mistake
but it's still a mistake that's why you
called you knew it was a mistake you
didn't call up and defend the action you
said it was wrong
it's a wrong response to a horrible
situation agreed
I agree and it's not sustainable you
can't keep doing it over and over
no what can I do moving forward I just I
don't know I gotta I know I gotta stop
and I just can't yeah you can't yeah
you tell you what you hang on we're
gonna set you up on the Dr John deloney
show and let you have a little more time
with John because uh the top of the hour
has run all over the top of us my
brother and we don't leave you hanging
so you hang on we'll continue the
conversation on the Dr John deloney show
and we're going to send you a copy of
his book own your past change your
future and then I'll get you started as
well that puts this hour the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]